ladies and gentlemen an international
star twice winner of the Academy Award
for Best Performance as an actress
Elizabeth Taylor
good evening it's lovely to be here
it's nice to be back in Hollywood I have
worked all over the world and found
Hollywood in Rome in France in London it
came from here I started here when I was
10 years old and it's always a thrill
for me to come back films have helped
bring a sense of the American land the
American purpose and the American Dream
to people everywhere tonight saluting
the 200th year of this land the by
centennial year let us recall that
original purpose and reaffirm that
necessary dream please join us to sing
America the Beautiful
there's been
ABC congratulate Jack Nicholson for his
Academy award-winning performance in One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest one week
from tonight see him in the exciting
lusty movie that made him a star five
Easy Pieces on the ABC Monday night
movie that's next Monday at 9:00 8:00
central
due to mature subject matter parental
discretion is advised
this is a bee